my name is Sebastian Gonzalez and I'm
gonna be surprising my mom with the
tattoo honestly we could get any number
of reactions from my family something
about tattoos just speak to me it's dope
but they wouldn't let me get one so none
of my family has ever gotten a tattoo I
don't think my mom's gonna be too happy
I ended up choosing a koi fish just
because it fits in with the whole Zen
vibe of my family I'll be getting a
dragon tattoo my mom's pretty smart but
also I really dig dragons a little bit
nervous but at the same time I think
this is gonna be great what kind of kid
was Sebastian
he was such a good kid he just was
always very just listen very proud of
you you know I'd never want to do
anything that would take away from that
pride that you have well I want to give
him his space but I would hope that he
was honest with me you know yeah do you
remember when I was like talking to the
two of you about Tom's birthday like the
weekend before last yeah and I got a
little bit heavily under the influence
well there's like one other thing I
ended up doing that night the real
reason why I brought you here wasn't for
really any of this just
there's me Sebastian where'd you get
that I got it like a couple weeks ago
that's gonna kill you dude no no all
right
oh it's beautiful
I got a koi fish was it painful I don't
really remember yeah well good I wanted
a tattoo and you said you like a
personal space I do what I want what is
it is it like a dragon with some smokes
and stuff like that it looks like
scribbles to me Sebastian
I love the koi fish it's kind of tied in
with paparazzo's a family had had a
beautiful koi pond and who actually had
a heart attack right next to his koi
pond and it was the most peaceful way
for him to go it was a blessing do you
even know like when you got the tattoo
like what does it mean to you it means
strength resilience and I really liked
Lord of the Rings so yeah I don't know
why I thought you know that you had
gotten in trouble with the law or you
decided to go sleep with a hooker and I
was like oh no throw tattoos mild I've
gone through this with him before I got
a tattoo when I was 18 and now I'm you
know 44 years old I want to get it off
I'm disappointed you know at least talk
to me about it and especially that color
I've considered tattoos myself what
would you get for a tattoo maybe an
octopus thank God it wasn't a prostitute
Oh like what else can you tell me all
right the tattoos fake mom let me see
the tattoos fake mom like you could
scrape it off just barely I just want to
give you a one last look the tattoo yeah
yeah because it's actually gonna wash
off really Dan how much it was gonna
cost us to get that lasered off
and so it was gonna get a laser off I'm
shaking I'm so it's a beautiful tattoo
though you didn't want to go for
something a little more marijuana give
you your personal space but like
something like that is big you know
tagging yourself and doing that is not
what makes you you is what makes you
[Music]
[Music]
don't get an octopus tattoo and nothing
the octopus would be a little scary
[Music]